so i got to say kevin i don't think i i
think it's the first time i don't think
i've ever interviewed someone
where i haven't heard the song before an
interview so there's a lot of secrets oh
really
oh around this song yeah so what's it
like to put together the song and try to
keep it like such a close
like tight group of who gets to hear it
yeah yeah i mean
it's it's amazing to get to even talk
about it before we
even release a song so thank you for uh
you know the
interview but yeah it's just kind of
like i feel antsy i want
i want people to hear it it sounds
awesome i worked
really hard on this so it's good it's
really exciting actually
yeah and you said it's kind of a new
sound for you like in what way is it new
yeah i mean i've been in the k-pop
industry for like 15 years so
you know just kind of going back to my
roots
uh you know i i've been very heavily
influenced by r
b and pop music so you know making a
track and a song with
american producers definitely is a sound
that my fans haven't
heard yet yeah so got it is the song
yes so people have now heard the song
the song is out there so what did you
want fans to hear doing this new song
yes so got it is my brand new usda
single
uh it's been a long time coming i know a
lot of my fans out in the us have been
waiting a long time for this
um so i'm super excited to let them hear
the new sound i've been working
on um i have been in k-pop for the past
15 years so
you know definitely k-pop is going to be
a big label for me
and title but uh sound wise i've been
working with
top producers in the states and also
coming back to my roots in america and
just writing songs out here
uh allowed me to kind of explore
different
sounds and colors that i've never really
tapped into when i was in the k-pop
scene so
yeah i'm really excited that my fans
finally get to hear it
yeah that's thing like i mean because
you're gearing it more towards the north
american audience did you
have a different approach to it for sure
yeah
um i think because k-pop is such a big
you know phenomenon um you know i really
wanted to
keep that k-pop essence uh as you can
see in the gothic music video
there is a dance performance so yeah i
still
still you know got the moves
yeah expressed my uh emotions and my
music with performance and that aspect
was great was very
important to me um but also uh i wanted
to focus on
just raw emotions and also the lyrics
this is
a song that i've uh co-written
with my producer it's one of my first
songs actually that i've
actually produced on so definitely
get to um be more like
i had more freedom writing this
definitely right yeah i saw some of your
videos of you doing rehearsal for the
music
music uh video so what was that like
like do you pick up choreography very
quickly
yeah i mean honestly there's been times
when we would learn a choreography
three days before the music video when i
was in
my k-pop boy band yukis but
luckily this time i had a little bit
more time than three days for sure uh i
had
around a week honestly to learn the
choreography
not that much different from three days
but
i would say that yeah it doesn't take me
too long to learn the choreography
yeah and if you've been able to perform
at all like say over the past like year
or so like when we've been dealing with
kobe have you performed at all
yeah i mean you know it's been a really
weird year for all
through this pandemic so i've done a lot
of online streaming
concerts um and i don't know if you've
ever joined
a virtual concert but you know
people who are watching it at home it's
it's definitely a new experience but for
artists it was quite a struggle because
we live off of that energy we feed off
of each other's energy
in the venue or whether it's outdoors or
not
i mean it's just that that synergy that
happens throughout a
you know concert but for a virtual
concert without having the feedback and
just like fans
constantly like screaming out your name
or kpop fans they actually
sing along with you and they do these
little fan chants which is really cool
so without that it was really awkward
but it's something that i had to
kind of get used to because there's a
new norm yeah and i guess a little bit
you can reach a more international
audience by doing a virtual concert too
like
what has it been like for you to see the
k-pop explosion
internationally over the past few years
wow it's been
such a crazy journey i felt it first
hand too because you know when i
first debuted there weren't that many
international
or foreign members in these k-pop groups
and i guess i was kind of like the
front-line
pioneers for you know um
crossing over back to korea you know uh
because i am korean american it was
you know it was a new thing uh for k-pop
but to see
it become more globalized especially um
not in just the fandoms but in k-pop
groups as well
yeah and then just getting more
recognition and uh
social media playing a big role in in
this
huge breakout um it was really cool to
see that
and you know it was just kind of
inevitable i i knew it was gonna come
it was just a matter of time but uh
really with
science gangnam style and bts and
blackpink and
so many other kpop groups that you know
are just super super talented
getting recognition out in america and
north america is just
such a you know mind-blowing experience
yeah yeah i know you kind of like walked
both lines but in terms of kpop
exploding in north america like do you
now have
certain like north american pop artists
that you'd love to collaborate because
obviously a lot of them are doing those
collaborations now right
of course of course um there was
there are so many first of all i would
want to collaborate with
ariana grande she is you know someone
who i
really you know was inspired by
and uh listening to her music so yeah
and a cool cool story is that my song
got it um the producer that i worked on
with
he actually produced ariana grande and
the weekend
off of her latest album called off the
table
and that was just really
just so so so like i couldn't really
wrap my head around the fact that i was
working with someone who
had the experience to work with someone
like ariana grande
and just to be in that same realm i
guess was
was something that i never thought would
have
happened but very good with opportunity
so did you like put a little bug in here
in his ear did you like make little
hints of like that you want to work with
ariana
yes i did i was like next time you go
over to her house
why don't you just nonchalantly play my
song for her you know yeah
yeah so so cool yeah and uh
there's so many other artists like love
and
khalid um bazi uh troye sivan
the weeknd uh there's just so many
artists that i would love to collaborate
with
yeah i'd love to hear that too and what
have you found like since uh leaving you
kiss like what have you found the
biggest changes of being so like what
surprised you the most
being a solo artist i would say
it's the creative freedom that i have um
not to say that i didn't have any when i
was in the group
but just right now um i've gotten to do
everything from directing producing
um promotions uh
just like designing styling just
everything is up to me basically i
i have the green light for everyone
to kind of work together so that's a
little intimidating and scary
when i first tapped into that world but
i'm getting used to it and it's a lot of
fun i see myself growing as an artist
every single day yeah and your fans are
called the clovers right
yes with the case kevin yes
yes so i mean especially over the past
year i've talked to a lot of a lot of
artists about
the importance of social media when you
aren't able to do you know face-to-face
concerts what's it been like for you
over the past year interacting with fans
on social media
wow honestly uh that's one of the
you know advantages and benefits i've
received from
this pandemic i know it's been a crazy
year and
it's been a rough one for a lot of us
but because of social media and because
there was such an online presence
that everyone was really longing that
really helped me
connect and engage my fans even more um
i would say even before the pandemic we
really had a great connection
like just me and my fans and my audience
uh but kind of
because of the pandemic it kind of it
exacerbated that
whole i guess community and that
that process because there were so many
new apps and
so many new programs that were able to
stay connected like twitch
and i was on a online virtual concert
pro app called sessions and i would do
like
one virtual concert a month and just
keeping that you know relationship
really tight-knit
and also showing them a very vulnerable
side of myself
um especially being me being my in my
bedroom in my home
there was just a lot of content that
they wouldn't have seen otherwise
right no yeah absolutely and obviously
you want to have a really big fan base
but say
releasing a song like god like a new
sound like do you feel the pressure too
that you have all these fans that are
really going to be
listening to this and analyzing it um so
my fans have been waiting a long time
for this it's
it's been over a year since my last
release
um you know being pandemic everything
kind of slowed down
but yeah they're they're really looking
forward to it and i
i wouldn't say i feel pressured i'm just
feeling more anxious
to let them hear it because i know
they've seen
me produce it i've given them updates
almost every day sometimes i would give
them little teasers here and there so
they really were
you know um along the journey like for
the ride with me uh so
they're just super super stoked and
super happy to
for me to finally release more music
this year right so what do you want fans
to hear in god like what do you want
them to take away from
it i want them to take away
um a new part of me that they've never
seen so
uh i know i've been i keep saying it's
like a new side of you side of me but
this release is something that i've
produced 100
like just it was all my idea and of
course all
you know my team uh whether being the
producer
and my and my my manager and just every
like all the creative people around me
like
i'm very grateful for this opportunity
for letting me
be able to have full control and i don't
think my fans have seen that yet
and um it's just more raw and authentic